what does it take to get a loan i got a
great question from my newsletter
readers love you guys namu casa who
wrote in to say what does it take to get
a loan and how can you pay it if you
want to start a small business so a lot
of entrepreneurs when they're thinking
of getting started they need the money
to get launched they think bank how do
we get money from the bank and get a
loan to start a company the thing to
remember here is most banks are not
startup friendly banks do not like
entrepreneurs because they don't like
risk they want something they can take
right they'll finance your house because
if you can't make a payment they're
gonna take your house and so with a
startup business banks don't like
lending money
typically if you are under three years
in business
then the only way they'll give you money
is based on a personal guarantee which
means you have to personally guarantee
that you're gonna pay back the money so
if your business goes under you're still
on the hook so it's not really a small
business loan it's a personal loan for
you and that's going to just depend on
your credit history if you have good
credit you can get the loan you don't
have good credit you're not going to get
the loan
and so banks are typically not the place
to look for but i would also you know
encourage you
not to start a business on the loan
because you're in debt and you're paying
money back
and you're not making anything yet and
the problem with entrepreneurs at the
start is the business that you start
with is really the business you end up
with you have to make lots of changes
the assumptions that you make will be
wrong the things that you think will
work won't work and other things will
and you have to change and figure it out
understand the market that's how it goes
with entrepreneurs you look at the
successful entrepreneurs you look at
what they started with it's never what
they ended up with they always had to
change many times before they hit their
big idea
and so all this time while you're
experimenting you're losing money
because you have to pay back this bank
loan
if you want to get started i'd say
bootstrap find a way to get it started
without spending any money start it as a
service if you need to get close to your
customers learn what they need learn how
you can help them instead of going into
personal debt to get this company
launched
another great way to do it is to get a
job
go work for somebody and don't just get
a job to make money get a job to learn
the reason why you get a job is to learn
you work to learn i have an entire zuga
guide that's dedicated to working to
learn this break down all the steps on
how to do it but basically you want to
find somebody who has done what you want
to do who's accomplished what you want
to accomplish and go work for them you
get paid so you're not worried about you
know paying your bills you're getting
paid to learn you're making industry
contacts you're making mistakes while
getting paid it's like going to
university but getting paid to do it
you're making contacts so that when you
launch your business you already know
what you're doing you don't need the
money you can line up clients
that's the better way to do it and to
fund it than to go into debt and take on
a personal loan to launch
so maybe not the answer you wanted to
hear
but that's my advice
believe those who watch like the video
thumbs up below let me know what you
think let me know if you've gone to the
bank and tried to get funding and were
accepted or rejected your experiences
leave it in the comment section below
you have a question for me leave it
below too i'll make a video response
just like this and if you want to see
more videos like this click on my face
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much i'll see you soon
you